well we've been talking this morning
already to uh Penny mordant and to
Yvette Cooper the shadow home sector in
we hope to be able to talk to Peter
Madison and Naomi long in a moment but
just to remind you uh penny mordant and
I talked at some length about the news
emerging from the talks between the
Prime Minister and the parties in
Northern Ireland and the EU which appear
I only say appear to be heading towards
some conclusion and here's what the
leader of the House of Commons had to
say
there are encouraging signs but the
Prime Minister has said that there is
still hard work to be done and everyone
will be pulling together to ensure that
we're giving that deal the best chance
possible what matters here and the prime
minister is very focused on this is what
the people of Northern Ireland think
about this deal this has to be
acceptable to all communities in
Northern Ireland and the EU is aware of
that so I I wish them well I think it
would be great if we can arrive at that
point but that's the test it's not what
I or any other member of the commons
thinks it's the people of Northern
Ireland
well let's now speak to a man who knows
a thing or two about trying to strike
deals between the parties in Northern
Ireland and in Brussels I'm joined now
by the former Northern Ireland secretary
and EU trade commissioner Peter now Lord
mandelson good morning Lord mandelson
good morning
now um
Terry you were responsible for
implementing The Good Friday agreement
um do you think though we don't know the
details of it but what we understand of
the rumored deal do you think that that
endanges that agreement in any way
if we get a deal over the Northern
Ireland protocol which is an essential
part of our overall deal with the
European Union post-brexit it will do
more than anything else to support the
Belfast Good Friday agreement it will
reinforce the peace process and help
stop any return to the violence that
we've seen in Northern Ireland in
previous decades so I'm hoping very much
indeed that the UK government and the EU
have now found a landing zone for
revising how the original Northern
Ireland protocol was operating I think
that's the important thing to achieve
and I hope very much that they're going
to be successful
you in fact it did describe the protocol
as I think your words were not perfect
um does that mean that you think that it
was inadequate as a basis for agreement
or simply needed essentially some
updating some tweaking
What what is the
is it an obstacle or is it really
something that
we should invest in
it was the essential thing to pre to put
in place
but the way in which it was done was not
satisfactory and the way it's operated
since has not been satisfactory I mean
Boris Johnson imposed it without
consultation with the unionists and
others in Northern Ireland in the first
place
he then set about uh repudiating it
having told lies about it to unionists
in Northern Northern Ireland and in the
process wrecked our partnership with the
Republic of Ireland
I did so much to destroy trust between
Britain and the European Union so I hope
he's not going to come in and start
wrecking everything all over again a
period of Silence on his part I think
would now be welcome but here's the
point Trevor
although the protocol itself is an
essential part of the overall
post-brexit deal it creates special
trading relations uh for Northern
Ireland which avoid uh you know a hard
border being reimposed between North and
South Island
in my view the European Union
frankly approached its implementation in
a rather clunky way I've been over
literal over overly strict and I'm glad
that the European union now has decided
to step back reconsider and approach
things in a rather more flexible way
that's what's needed now
I want to ask you about what they might
be thinking about in Brussels and moon
but if we made can I just ask you about
the dup and also about Mr Johnson's
intervention this morning uh he seems to
be saying that we should retain the
protocol bill as not as an option as a
if you like a threat to the EU penny
more than described his intervention
this morning as helpful on the ground
that it would remind the EU I guess that
this doesn't have to happen and that
they perhaps need to make more
concessions what what do you make of
that
there's nothing that Boris Johnson is
doing now or indeed throughout our
recent history with the European Union
that could possibly be described as
helpful he's wrecking he's trying to
wreck the thing
um because he's opposed to the Prime
Minister he wants
he and his supporters want to undermine
the Prime Minister it's just a sort of
continuation of the fratricidal war that
we see in the conservative party so I
really hope that Boris Johnson removes
himself entirely from this matter you
know we don't we don't need him wrecking
uh things uh anymore look the the point
is this that
in my view
insufficient uh attention concern was
shown by all parties the EU and the
British government towards unionist and
other sensitivities in in Northern
Ireland and they're repairing that and
that's a good thing to be doing
but it will also enable us if we get
this agreement in place to repair our
relationship between Britain and the
Republic of Ireland which is so
important in continuing to uphold the
Belfast Good Friday agreement in the
peace process but also to rebuild trust
and to reconnect Britain with the
European Union not to go back into the
European Union of course but to get a
sensible working relationship between us
you probably understand the if I can but
it's very political psychology of
Brussels and of Belfast better than
anyone else because you've had to deal
with uh both uh cities uh from the
inside
the dup says in one of its seven tests
that it can't accept anything that
involves uh if you like a democratic
deficit i.eu institutions including the
ecj having a role in determining certain
kinds of policies the EU
wants uh any kind of disputes to be
settled at least in part with the
involvement of the ecj
is it conceivable that those two
mindsets can be brought together
yes it is possible and it's very
important that that that that happens
look the
arrangements are that Northern Ireland
in a sense is being given a very
privileged position to take advantage
both of the uk-wide market and economy
but also the opportunities that are
offered by a special association with
Europe's single Market
that's going to be very important by the
way for Northern Ireland's economic uh
future there are real advantages real
opportunities now available uh to
Northern Ireland and I'd like to you
know see those properly uh realized but
I would just make two points about this
whilst the rules of the single Market
will apply however flexibly and and uh
uh and and wisely
um there there will be occasions when
some arbitration is needed and that's
why the role of the European Court comes
into play but I hope that that the court
and its role will be downplayed I hope
the European Court takes a very clear
back seat in the operation of these
Arrangements but secondly and I said
this to former colleagues of mine in the
European commission Before Christmas it
would be a very good idea if the
European Union in its approach to
Northern Ireland it consults not just
the unionists but all the parties the
Northern Ireland assembly as a whole
in it how it goes about uh operating
these arrangements and if they've got to
be adjusted or changed in the future
then consult people talk to people and I
think the European Union are now mindful
of the need to do that and I very much
hope they'll do so in the future
can I talk to you about the other big
political development or another big
political development of the week and
that is the uh announced resignation of
Scotland's first Minister Nicola
sturgeon
so it's goodbye Nicola good news for
labor
I think it is good news for labor but
you know what's more important for labor
and its electoral prospects is not what
happens to Nicholas sturgeon but but how
the changes that have been brought about
in the labor party by KIA stammer's
leadership are embraced by the UK
electorate as a whole the changes in the
labor party are much more important to
our electoral prospects than what's
going on in the SNP
but of course it opens up an opportunity
for us in Scotland we badly need to win
back seats we've got a superb leader of
Scottish labor and Asawa who works very
very closely with Kia stammer and I
think that the opportunity now is for
labor not to offer a different version
of nationalism to the Scottish people
but an alternative to nationalism what
the labor party will do for the Scottish
economy and jobs and skills the Health
Service and Health Care delivery
transport education fighting crime yes
these are the big issues now on which
the next election is going to be fought
I want to come to one of those big
issues in a moment but just very um
uh quickly on the politics of this you
talked about the changes in labor the
equality and Human Rights Commission
this week uh said that labor was in
effect out of special measures on the
question of anti-Semitism and the leader
has basically has said that Jeremy
corbyn will not be a labor candidate
um now there's some questions about
whether he can actually guarantee that
but
um is that the right decision or is it
just a provocation yes it is that it is
the right decision look it's also
inevitable I mean Jeremy corbyn who
played such a part and was so
instrumental in in tolerating
anti-Semitism in the labor party so much
for part of the problem it has chosen
himself not to be part of the solution
and therefore I think his withdrawal is
inevitable
when the very last brief question if I
may um leg party today is talking about
uh a new regime on the anti-social
Behavior Uh cracking down on people who
are repeatedly disrupting Town centers
and so on
um it struck me reading their release
there was quite an echo of uh something
that was uh said during your time in
government to be tough on crime
um I look back to someone see Jack
Straw's comments about getting Winos and
squeegee Merchants off the street
um
Back to the Future but maybe back to New
labor
now I think what's important is that the
the current leadership and Shadow
cabinet front bench of the labor party
look look at all that we did as a
government learn all the lessons and
then see seeing the new challenges uh
that the country faces some of which are
similar some of which are new
you know take what we did forward adapt
it build on it I mean apply it to the
second century second decade of the 21st
century I mean nobody wants to have
turned the clock back but I think that
you know what you're seeing in the labor
party leadership now
you know it's a lot of sense a lot of
practicality kirstalm has made it
absolutely clear that he wants to fight
the next election on the center ground
of British politics okay and I think
that uh you know strong modern
center-left policies are what a a
required by the country now no equally
there's a fringe in the labor party that
wants to contest that
my view is that the labor party can't
make two offers at the next election it
has to be a starma offer and not a sort
of Corp in tinged uh offer and I think
if those people in the labor party can't
get behind starma then they should be
the ones who step back
Lord mantelson thank you so much for
your time this morning pleasure